هربوا تاركين بلادهم سعيا للامن والامان
ولم يتوقعوا ان تصلهم تهديدات النظام
الايراني الى كندا يتظاهرون في شوارع
تورنتو كل اسبوع مطالبين الحكومه بمنع
دخول انصار النظام وادراج الحرس الثوري
الايراني على قائمه الارهاب
الكنديين في كندا لذلك فرضنا سلسله عقوبات
تقريبا
وسنراقبك حتى نعرف عنوانك كما ذهبوا الى
منزلنا واستجوبته
الاول مباشر وهذا ينفذ فورا والاخر غير
مباشره عن طريق ارسال الرسائل او تهديدهم
بعائلاتهم وهذا ما حدث مع الصحفي طه
مامي
حاول النظام الايراني والتسلل الى الجاليه
بالنشاطات مختلفه ثقافيه او دينيه ولم
تهتم الحكومه الكنديه كثيرا بانشطه عملاء
النظام الذين حاولوا تهدينا حتى انهم
ذهبوا الى منزل عائلتي في ايران لاكف عن
نشاطي قبل نحوي عامين كان لديهم تهديد
مباشره حيث قتل ناشط سياسي في منطقه
ماركام وقتلت امراه في مدينه باري ولم
تقدم الشرطه الكنديه حتى الان اي تفسير
حول الجريمه التي مر عليها نحو 11 شهرا
لكن هناك اناشيد
من خلالها كندا للحد من دخول انصار النظام
اراضيها واستجابه للمطالب المحتاجين اخرها
عقوبه على مرتضى طلائق قائد شرطه طهران
السابق الذي ظهرت صوره في احدى صاله
الرياضه بكندا
التحديدات هو المراقبه التي يتعرض لها
الايرانيون على ارض كندا ليس جديده لكن
الجديد ان الحكومه الكنديه اعترفت بها
رسميا ومعتمده على تقارير مخابراتها وحضرت
نظام الايراني منتدياتها رفع السعد
العربيه تورنتو